اذا بينما تؤكد اسرائيل وفق وزير ماليتها
انه لا مصلحه لها في استمرار المواجهات
تربط توقفها عن القصف بوقف اطلاق الصواريخ
من غزه تقول الفصائل الفلسطينيه انها
ماضيه في ردها على الاغتيالات التي نفذتها
قوات الاحتلال كان اخرها اغتيال علي غالي
مسؤول القوه الصاروخيه في سرايا الفجر في
سرايا القدس عفوا فجرا هذا اليوم في
التفاصيل نتحدث عن اكثر من 500 صاروخ قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي انها اطلقت من غزه
واعترف بنحو ثلاثمائه وستين صاروخ او اكثر
بقليل
اجتازت حدود قطاع غزه طبعا يقول ان القبه
الحديديه
اعترضت نحو
150 من هذه الصواريخ التي اطلقت من قطاع
غزه
ابرز الاستهدافات كانت اصابات مباشره
لمبان في كل من عسقلان هنا في غلاف غزه
ايضا كذلك في مجمع اشكول كما تحدث زميلنا
الياس كرام قبل قليل حيث هذه المنطقه طبعا
المقابله لمعبر كرم ابو سالم قبل قليل
كانت اخر الاصابات المباشره
لمباني سكنيه وزراعيه وللمره الخامسه طبعا
منذ صباح هذا اليوم في اشكول جنوب القطاع
في المنطقه المقابله لجنوب القطاع في نقب
الغربي ايضا استهدف احد الصواريخ معبدا او
معهدا دينيا في نتيفوت هنا في النقب
الغربي لكن دون وقوع اصابات بالعموم كانت
منطقه غلاف غزه بالكامل في حاله تاهب امني
مستمر صافرات الانذار لم تتوقف في معظم
المدن في كيسوفيم فيسبيروت في نادي
الان اسدود ووصولا حتى كما ذكرنا لي
المناطق جنوب القطاع في اشكول كل ذلك ياتي
طبعا تبعا لرشقات الصواريخ التي يتم
اطلاقها من غزه ايضا بناء على ذلك منذ
الامس وسعت وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
دائره الطوارئ هنا الى نحو 80 كم هي دائره
تشمل كل ما تشاهدونه هنا على الخريطه من
جنوب تل ابيب الى اشكول جنوبا في النقب
الغربي حتى غرب القدس هنا في منطقه
استهدف صاروخ بالامس يصل مداه تقريبا الى
75 كيلو متر كما وصلت الى جنوب تل ابيب
بالامس ايضا حركه المرور كما رصدناها
اليوم في خرائط جوجل ما تزال معظم الطرق
في غلاف غزه مغلقه من قبل الاحتلال هنا
هذه المناطق طبعا منعا لاستهداف السيارات
فيها كذلك المدارس ما زالت معطله هنا في
حدود اكثر من اربعين كيلو متر في غلاف غزه
وقد اجلت السلطات الاسرائيليه الاف
الاشخاص من مناطق غلاف غزه لاسيما
اذا في المقابل يتحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
قصف نحو 150 هدفا في قطاع غزه طبعا دمرت
تلك الغارات منازل بشكل كامل في كل من بيت
حانون وبيت لاهيا وايضا استهدفت منزلا
مهجورا شرق خان يونس هنا كذلك يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه اغار على اربعه مواقع او
ما قال انها اربعه مواقع عسكريه للجهاد
الاسلامي بينها مخازن سلاح وذخيرات اذا
ايضا افاد مراسل الجزيره من غلاف غزه بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يستخدم هنا في هذه
المناطق المسيرات بكثافه حول قطاع غزه في
اجواء المنطقه الشماليه خاصه والغايه طبعا
من ذلك رصد النقاط الاستطلاع ومنصات اطلاق
الصواريخ هنا في غزه ومحاوله احباط عمليات
اطلاق الصواريخ قبل تجاوزها لحدود قطاع
غزه ايضا يستخدم الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه
المسيارات الزنانه كما يسميها اهل غزه
يستخدمها لعمليات القصف كما راينا في بيت
حانون هنا حيث كان القصف بطائره مسيره
بالعموم يمكننا القول ان التصعيد ما زال
سيد الموقف قبل دقائق طبعا نقلت وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه عن مسؤولين ان
اسرائيل رفضت وقف سياسه الاغتيالات رفضت
تسليم جثمان خضر عدنان في مقابل صفقه لوقف
اطلاق النار وبالتالي يمكن القول ان
الساعات القادمه قد تشهد مزيدا من التصعيد
طبعا نحن نتابع معكم اولا باول كل هذه
المستجدات وسيكون لنا لقاءات اخرى لشرح كل
ما يحدث هنا على الخريطه اما الان نعود
الى بقيه التغطيه المباشره وملفاتها